house boom raise money spring welcome to
Lhasa who are we going to Fabul eyes
today stephen collins confesses what
stephen you did not do that stephen way
next year's pati faces it's maddening
back yeah it looks pretty good
oh I know what we can do with this I
just got a weird look so good
you look so get Steven you don't even
know I don't know where I'm going with
this
why not let's get weird nice yes yeah
yeah I'm not gonna pay for stocks don't
make the stocks harder to buy than they
are to Photoshop away the same their
watermark so get your neck said yeah
this is that's creepy it's done let's
see what your brother think oh my
[ __ ] god
report report him not me come on
not even death it will tear them apart
hello when you breath tell me that's too
much that means that means I'm going in
the right direction
next up you bro suggested Daniel
Radcliffe gotcha
whoa oh you should not have done that
Daniel big mistake Daniel whoo my god
can't what
what am I doing with my life bros is
this is this where we are at now why are
you laughing I'm serious
Danielle confirmed next Disney Princess
those has to be the best damn sunglasses
I ever seen in my life
just look at them I see I seriously
wonder how do I get them sorry this is
just getting too weird for me
I'll have to quit it there let's see
what you guys think of this alright my
god stop stop telling me to stop I will
never be able to unsee that
oh you're welcome damn where's Kim
hubba-hubba Ryan Gosling
how many happy to help I have no idea
with them what I'm doing here just kind
of going with it God what happened I
like how this belly button looks like a
[ __ ] amount what happened
what the [ __ ] I have never been this
turned on in my entire life
this is probably the best picture of the
internet let's see what your breasts
think still hot I think you made him
hotter well see you good there you go
people say I harass the Lebanese no
making the blue collar that's all I ever
cared about it would be funnier if you
changed a mouth section with his belly
oh all right price that's all the time I
had to finalize today next time we're
gonna Fabul eyes Gandalf
like if you enjoyed this episode but I
really appreciate it and hit subscribe
for my birthday and I will see you bros
and then
excellent as always stay awesome Road